大家好然後我今天給大家分享的是這個和編譯相關的一個知識然後這個部分的話就是說我最近也在對這個移動這塊開發有了一些想法就因為移動開發從很早以前吧應該是08年吧蘋果開始推出這個就是那個蘋果手機以後到現在已有十幾年的時間了然後很多老的APP呢
就特别是大家用的比较多的VP他们实际上已经就是这个工程已经有了很长很长的时间然后这块呢就说可能涉及到很多老的代码然后没有用的代码就是连久的工程到这个阶段是需要做一些优化的然后就是我今天主要讲的可能就是说怎么使用这个编译的接触去对这种连久的工程做优化第二个人就说
把功能做完优化以后然后怎么去在开发中提高开发的效能然后移动端呢和这个前端还有后端比较来说的话它有很大的不同就是前端和后端它的代码就即使放了很长的时间如果用户没有去用的话实际上这个代码就真的是没有用了然后对于客户端不一样客户端用户是要下到自己的机器上的
会占用自己的这个空间所以说你如果不去腰化它你不把一些没有用的去掉它就会一直占着这个就是用户的手机空间就是一个是对用户的体验不好然后以后影响这个家载这个程序就对类似的占用还启动了速度然后谁说呢移动端这方面就是我觉得也是一个很重要的经过这么长的时间很多公司
就包括我以前代入的公司到现在都是或许做相关的优化就是把一些没有用的代码就清理掉所以说呢就是现在就是比较明确的一个就是对连脚的工程什么优化要有一个方向就是有很多方向就比如说压缩啊或者是主要是压缩吧然后或者是呃在些什么地方去买点然后找有用
不好意思打断一下就是你能不能把你那个视频可能弄成单个的因为现在直播间有同学就你现在那个视频应该是成串的就你你先停一下共享然后把那个对对对对那个视频看一下叫就是可以弄成那种是显示当前的你再共享一下吧再重新共享一下你就共享ppt就好了好的好的现在可以了吧现在好些了吗我看一下
对因为你那个我想一下应该是我看现在好像是好的我也在这个看直播ok没问题没问题那你继续吧不好意思那个所以确定一个方向吧就说对客户当然说就是如果要优化09的工程有一个方向就是要把这个没用的代码去掉然后为了去掉这些无用代码实际上早在这个17年开始就1517年吧
就已经有很多人在做这个事情就最开始做的方法呢是什么样子呢就说会从产物涨涨因为产物这个嗯比较浓密就对于这个移动这个iOS的这个编译出来的产物卖起来的文件在他的这个data之段里面就有一个这个这个这个之段就是objc cellref这个这个他是干嘛用的他是会
会在你编译的时候就是把这个每个方法它互相之间这个调用它有没有被调用的然后就放在这里面去然后如果要去掉它的话呢就首先我们要在编译的这个linkmap里就得到了所有这个方法就是把它获取然后再从这使用这个命令行吧然后就能把这些调用的这些方法就把它筛选出来然后这样来说的话就全部减去这个已经调用的
剩下的就是无用无用的方法这看起来好像没有什么问题但实际上对于这个Object C这一门语言来说的话就是很多方法它算是调用了但它实际上它可能没有真的调用还有一些是在运行过程中调用的所以说这个方法不是那么的准确就是特别是对于这种运行时的调用的方法它实际上刚才这种方式是查不到的
那应该怎么办呢?然后后来就有了一种方案就是说从编译的这个前端长手就说很多就说我们写这个Object C它这个代码它就是你看这个地方有我们写Object C的这个调用的这个方式有直接就是类调方法这种写法那另外特别是第二种就是perform select就这种是存在运行的时候去调用的
这种方法就是但是呢像刚才前面提到了这个从产物找手的话是找不出来的然后这种呢只能从这个前端值就是编译的这个前端找手去根据他的这种写法把这个方法的调用找出来然后同样对于这个uik的这个库里面他也会有很多这个snike上一些事件然后这些事件他里面带的参数都是一些这个制服串然后制服串
它就是运行过程中它根据这个字母创去查找对应的这个方法然后得到哪些方法是调用所以说后来就是因为很多不是查不出来所以就只能通过这个直接从圣读代码然后从代码这个层面去找然后还有什么Time啊KVR都是这种形式然后这个前端呢它是怎么去找呢实际上前端已经
就是lm的前端有client,有swift c,然后对于这个client来说的话,它是可以直接去写这个插件,然后就可以去,然后这个插件它有不同的类型,然后首先它要,它有继承这个sd,sd就与法术,然后呢,再去便利它各个节点,然后这样一些事件,然后通过这个重载的这些事件里面,你可以去找到它哪些是用的perform select,
然后你又能得到他的这个参数pass arguments就能得到这个参数然后从而知道哪些是在写的时候去主动调这个方法的然后再来说有些我们在场面里面找不到的这些方法可以通过这个client来找查然后刚才的这种呢就说他解决的是什么问题呢他实际上解决的就是说静态的就是我们在上线之前我们通过静态的这个手段去找到这些无用的方法
然后实际上很多的代码它虽然调用了它也有可能是就是在这个代码这种运行过程中我直接指名要去调用它虽然这样写了但是实际上用户它并没有去点它然后有些做法是什么做法就是说我可能通过在页面里面插上买点然后去找但是这样的力度太大了还有一种就是通过这个内内的这个出使化然后去找哪些内被出使就是被用到过来
但是如果很多的类都写的特别特别的大的话那就那就这个颗粒度比较大你根本没法具体到这个这个细节里面去你找到的也是很偏面的所以说呢还有什么方法呢就怎么把这个粒度降小就是不是光从这个类上面去去找可能从这个方法来找就哪些让我用户他用了这些方法没有那些方法实际上在这个测试
他們測他有沒有測血那這個時候呢他們基本上就是說會用這種colder coverage就單碼覆蓋率這種方式去做然後來通過它不斷的試然後看有沒有就是說就是有就是真實情況有沒有用到這些函數但是colder coverage呢它不光是它這個力度小就是有點太小它是每一行它都會去擦裝然後去記錄
那使用起来的话呢就说呃他能能做到然后方法呢就说大概这样就是你可以通过运行这个命理然后呢或者是在这个scode大功能里面你再生flag里面再加上这个这个这个Option就让他能够在这个driver就是那个编译的这个driver这个阶段然后去指定他特定的事情这个Option然后可以生成这些数据
然后这个数据也可以用对应的LVM的这个命令把它生成这个可以生成报告的这个数据然后通过这个命令就能生成一份报告这个报告就会显示出所有的这个代码使用的情况就是每一行每一行用了它都能给你列传但这种呢是有代价的就说你可能只是在线下的运行时能找到无用的代码你是没法把它带上带到线上去
然后code coverage还有一个就是它很难定制所以说呢现在要用到比这个类啊更小级别更细腻多了这个发案然后就说直接用code coverage肯定是不行的然后呢更灵活的话呢就是得看这个code coverage它底层用的哪些技术它下面用的实际上是fusing的这个技术这个是用在很多立项和安全上的一种技术fusing的实际上就是说
它的原理就是刚才差不多也说到了就说首先LVM里面它有FuzzingFuzzing是Label Fuzzing然后它下面用的是Sensitive Courage它的原理就在编译的时候它给每个函数还有基本快还有这些编辑进行一个插庄就能插的地方都插上了然后插庄完了以后它就能分析它运行的这个情况有很多库可以推进就是
就是有这个文件这个级别这是比较老的一种技术然后再到后来就像这个LVM基于IR这个然后它有一平台叫KD然后呢如果不是这个LVM的就是比如说我不是这个C源或者Swift的源或者Rust的是其他的源的话它可以用这个Cume这个模式它实际上就是原理是类似的它就是把这个最终的这个产物
然后反倒这个qm它的这个ir就是把它就是反变一层这个qm然后再里面去查 查完要再去执行这样来说进行这个代码的覆盖然后比较有代表的就是rfl它的原理和这个这个live fitting是很在世的但它生成的这个ir语言是不一样的然后这个live fitting就是lng然后另外还有
还有这种OSSFuse它是把各个流行的Fusein库做了一个整合做了一个大的平台就这一块感兴趣可以去详细了解一下因为很多情况就是如果不是开源的代码是一些比如你感兴趣的它又没有开源的代码然后你想去了解它的一些技术或者想做一些自己的分析就是用这种Fusein技术是比较好的然后接下来看到就说
对iLVM来说的话它fusing的底层用的是sensitive coverage所以这一块实际上也是可以单独去使用加上这样一个选项flag加上去以后你本身的工程代码里写上回调的时间你就可以通过回调时间获取到
比如像这个 func他表示就是我只处理这个函数相关的然后你也可以处理这种代码块相关的你就都可以在这个地方去进行设置然后这个地方你就能获取到对应的这个回调然后在这里面插上你自己想插的就是比如说我可以插这个这个地方如果是function然后我实际上是回调里面我打字字以后他也能把这个所谓这个函数都给列传就是我
这是运行过程中就能直接把这个就说我哪些运行的运行的顺序是什么样子的然后每个韩数调用多少次就都能得到然后对于使用这个sensitive coverage那有什么问题那实际上最大的一个问题啊就是说它编译特别的慢就非常的慢它们每个地方都会都会插进去就即使你把范围说小了它实际上也会有白名单黑名单但它依然会那里的编译很慢
而且你也没法自己进一步的定制就比如说我要精减这个擦装的指令就没法做到因为经你把擦装指令减少了实际上你带到线上去验证的时候你的大碗量也会非常的小就对包的体积影响也会打得最小所以说呢到这个就要考虑一下就是我们是不是能够自己去也去做一个这个PASS30tube底层用的就是PASS这么这个自己做了一个PASS
然后这个帕子只不过被这个L官方集成进去然后我们这次帕斯的之前呢就说这个帕斯它会用到的主要就是LVM按钮所以我们要先了解这个LVM按钮LVM的这个按钮呢它实际上也是一个比较低级别的语言它跟指令这种级就说简单的说来比较像是它这个很低级的语言
但是虽然是第一语言他实际上还能够和高级语言的这些特性给一一的对应上去比如说类啊结构体啊这些都能对上因为高级语言它就是其实这个地方就是属性二二是开发的其实想留意这块也并不是很大因为OoC来说的话它实际上就是基于C来做的然后它这门高级语言和CZN的区别它全部体现在了它的运行时尚
所以去看这个Runtime的实现比如说类它是一个跳转的直征然后到其它的属性和它类里面的方法就是它的直征的一些偏音量就类是这样在这个Ir里面其实也是一样的只不过一个是在运行过程中去处理然后对这个Ir来说的话它实际上是在编译节能去处理的另外Ir它是会在这个地方合作优化的
下面是一个流程图就是对我们来说这个前面这些语言就是有很多种swift语言语言呢他们编完了以后就用前站的这些工具编完了以后他实际上就会到了这个中间这个过程昨天这个过程字尖码里面会去做一些优化这个优化就是用pass去做的然后最后再生成这个机器然后看到这个图啊就在这个图里面实际上这个过程是编译的时候是不会做的
就说我在练的话呢只是就是表明他这个就是后面会去讲这个lmlink是干嘛用的只是做一个事业就了解一下他每个bc就他中间这个这个代码他都会去做这个妖化最后再合到一起然后他的布局上就分为三个等级吧第一个大的等级就是文件级别的猫油然后这个里面就会有全局的一些东西获价里面然后还有韩束的这些声明呢
定义啊还是其他的这种比较针对文件这个级别的然后它里面包含的是这个方向就是函数函数里面函数它就就是这个参数啊什么它进入了这个block还有基础的这些这个就会很多这是主体就会有很多很多很多的block然后每个block他都会有自己的这个level然后这个level就是表明他的意思吧比如说有些循环的或者条件判断
或者是外奧最后再跳回来他有了内部他也可以执行完了以后比如说循环的他再跳回来他就有一个能跳的地方定义到啥然后对于BassBlock里面会有很多的这个指令指令就是就是一条全部的这个就是把这个数据往内算里面存了许愿然后计算起来就分就这种具体的计算和执行的指令这个操作吧就都在这个Inscription里面然后这个是返回的一个
特命了就退出返回了这样一个字所以它布局也比较的清晰简单高级的这个圆的特性它的也都能挠过进去那接下来这个了解挨挨后咋写这个要Pass就说我们如果要自己写Pass这个Pass还是还是得学一下然后写Pass来说我们先了解一下这个Pass就说Pass它首先它是专门去做这个这个优化的然后每一个Pass它都是独立的
因为rmrm这个项目它存在的时间已经非常的长了所以它这个共存结构就是目前它是很合理的它会把每个这个pass都做成一个独立的然后同时呢我做了这个pass它也不会影响这个rmrm整个的它这个结构培底线为它是一种插件就是我要用我就可以把它加进来然后每个pass之间它是能够有关联的它不是说它这个独立就完全和其他的就没有什么关联性的
它其实它也是可以有关联合能进行分组而且我写pass大家肯定会关心就是我可能有我比较擅长一些语言是不是能基于我现有的语言去写这个pass首先它的主要语言就是这个C++然后其次就是它提供了一个C的接口然后这个接口就比较稳定一些就C++的接口它会加入很多新的特性但是C的这个就是比较稳定一些也可以用C的这个接口去写
另外还能用swift写,swift写的话它本身是官方是没有提供这个swift接口的,然后swift写的话是需要就基于这个CR加,基于这个CR加现在还不太好做,然后基于C,然后你去包装一下,就是要去项目,用swift再去实现这些类啊,就是CR加的这个特性,其实也比较麻烦。
但是有一个比较好的消息就是SWIT马上也要支持生涯家了随说到时候SWIT就可以直接去调生涯家的结构就会很方便然后AR写PARS来说话就是有两种就是一种是指数分析然后你如果要插庄就是插路特定的指令就实际上会去改它的这个结构这样来说就需要进行一个转换就要继承于这个PassInfoMission然后呢同时呢这个Pass生成
有两种方式就一种是静态的就说调方式都是用这个OPT来调所以可以直接把它重新就是写就让那个OPT直接集成进去然后重新构建一个OPT这样就是一个静态的方式而另外一种的就是可以直接加这个参数选项然后把这个你的这个编号的这个方式这个动辣库把它加载进来
它有类似的PASS可以去参考它里面也有很多的样率我觉得都是可以去学习一下PASS来说它实际上是会有一个管理的工具叫PASS ManagerPASS Manager本身是继承于PASS Info Mission这个继承于它的意思就是表明PASS Manager实际上是可以改变PASS
因为PaaS Manager实际上是管理这个每个因为刚才也提到这个PaaS之间它实际上是可以互相有关联的它的关联就是通过它们之间的这个回调来关联起来的所以这个PaaS Manager它需要去处理这个回调然后让它能够去改变这个PaaS然后同时PaaS Manager它是满足这个PaaS concept然后这个PaaS concept就是遵循这个PaaS concept是PaaS model
PassMode相当上就是一个实力就是运行过程中的一个实力它保存这个Pass的所有的结构就都在这个PassMode里然后在我们写Pass的时候呢它会主要的东西都会在这个RUM的这个函数里面所以我们这个RUM在执行的时候它就会去执行这个Pass之前它会执行这个前日的这个callback然后执行完了以后它执行完了以后会执行这个这个就是后置的这个callback
想像这个都是由帕什麽样式把管理给他的,给他进去的。另外在整个帕什这一串的过程中,从这个Ir到最终的这个Ir里面可能会有很多帕什,而每一个帕什之间他们的全局的这种东西都是通过Alienize来记录,它会在整个Papela的管道中去流传。
然后接下来就针对最开始所有的这种情况就是我们怎么去插庄对吧就是我们怎么不是通过这个就是前端这个代码层面而是通过这个中间这个iR这个层层级去进行这个插庄然后可以看一下就是说刚才提到这个run的这个函数然后既然要插庄首先我们就要有一个能够
调用的这样一个方法比如说我要像刚才一样我跟每一个这样一个函数或者我们要查算这个地方然后然后去计个字字这个叫RoundTimeKnock然后我们要在这个ir的这整个这个环境里去取出这个方法出来所以他得到这个上传文context然后在这里面去去查找查找到这个RoundTimeKnock这是第一步而接下来不就是刚才也提到了这个
这个Ir的这个结构怕是它实际上是是超出这个Ir的所以说首先mode下面呢就是前面前置是modemode里面得到了这个functionfunction它里面就会有这个这个bbin就是basic block然后就在里面去便利便利一遍然后便利这个bblock就每个block里面呢它就会有各个的指令所以我们要插入指令就一定是在这个某个basic block里面就bbin里面去插这个指令
然后插入指令就这一段DNCastBinaryOperation这一段的实际上是在函数的最开始的意思就是互相当中最开始指令然后在最开始里面插下去就是它还没有执行我先把log方向插入进去这样来说它插入进去最多就有两条指令就能解决就是那样就非常小然后接下来我们再写完了这个方式就比如说变完以后成了一个共产会以后
然后我们怎么去用它调制啊怎么去使用我们可以选择用scode也可以用其他的但是scode的大家可能会更熟悉一些所以我们可以就说会用scode去做然后过程中就说我们可能需要有一个开源的这个client这个版本然后我们在这个scode的这个config里面去指定他为这个这个这个我们变了这个client这个开源这个版本然后世界家也是一样
然后接下来还有一个flag然后我们就选择了我们的pass就行了就是out of flag里面我选择我们的pass然后就可以这样我们就可以把它集成到我们构建这个环境里面去然后接下来我们说我就说一下这个第二点然后可能时间的关系我可能说得快一点然后第二个就是提效就是我们俗称的就是我们
改一方代码它立刻就能显示出一个效果目前有两种方案就是我们大家有两种方案就一个是InjectionStreet另外一个JescoJesco想要就是像Rerelative这种它自然就带有因为Jesco它本身就是一个解职线它就能在运营过程中就是你改完改了以后它立刻解职就执行出效果它自然就有这个优省然后对于原生的来说的话呢就是目前可以使用这个就可以了
然后它实际上是支持就是就是你只要用到这个inject就是spm里面你把inject加进去以后这几个就都能支持但是呢就是可能需要加一些代码然后呃在scode里面呢加上这个就可以就是interposal就可以了然后打他们lookup然后把这个每次你要进行这种一边写一边当中出效果呢就要把这个app打开
就行选择的工程目录就可以然后像这个Injection或者这种那个新这种发生它的原理是什么样子呢它的原理实际上就说刚才可以看到打开了这个就是麦克娃s这个这个程序它实际上就是Injection的一个serving这个这个server呢它会去监听这个scode这个工程文件里面的这些文件的更新情况这个文件更新完了以后它立刻就知道知道了以后呢
就赶紧用成一个就是把你改了这个文件然后变成这样一个动来库然后动来库呢就把它打开打开这样它就会更新了更新完了以后接着改改完以后呢迁迹靠的接着它变成这个mxl然后直接把它打开然后打开以后它实际上用的是什么技术呢?就是说它实际上会在你的这个卖销的这个
对这个字段里面插入这样一个interpose这个里面的数据是什么数据就是每个方法和大家替换的方法就放在这个里面然后到了运行过程中他见到这个方法他也能把换成你改完那个后的这个新的方法然后他其实显示这个小就是用了这样一个技术dyldinterpose然后对于就是说如果了解这个新的这个挺有的这个技术实际运用的话
它用的实际上是一个环境参数就是dyldinsertlibrary这个就等于一场算就对应到它的动态的这个库然后像svdr的preview它就是通过环境参数去做的然后还有一种方法实际上就是在运行工程中去换函数的这样一个就是dyldynamicinterpose就是可以根据这些关键计较就相关的这个技术但是原理
还是这样子就是需要有一个监听这个变化的这样一个serve然后变化完了后然后告知告知我们这个程序然后让它生成这个动作去给我们APP用大概就是这样一个过程目前发案呢就是它会有一些就是说可能有时候像像银接个属于它是缺少一些动作的话没法带上线可能也只能在线下去做
然后代码也会有很多轻弱然后新的框架新的适配因为它最终生成的这个中间的这个过程里是没法干预的所以说就设计到当然介绍课就不要说了这个加尔什惠布这个语言可能就还不熟悉学习里面新的语就比较麻烦所以说呢在刚才也提到就说IOM它的这个中间的这个过程的上次可以去更改这个指令的所以当我们需要在代码中去去加入什么
代码的时候我们实际上可以直接在这个中间这个过程加进去这样来说就不会影响咱们这个就是本身工程的这个代码就看不到啊但它虽然也有这些要要加入这样一些代码但是它实际上就是中间这个过程去完成所以说我们就要选择这个然后去解释这个爱啊这个语言这样来说的话这个爱啊我们就已经是一个更新不一样的能够更改的改完之后我们再去执行它然后就能
弥补前面的一些缺陷然后NN它的首先它设计的比较简单它是一个无线的计算器因为它不会考虑到最终的这个机器的这个代码所以机器它都是有限制的比如说它的这个计算器的数量我们要去管理但是如果对中间这一块中间原来说它是不用去关心这个的所以它就比较简单努力解释然后静态单一复制也是一样它只复制它不会去更改这个变量的
但是大家会想一个变量不停的它肯定要变嘛不然怎么叫变量所以它的方法就是在这个变量后面讲数字就不算哪家但是它总是单一的它只负责它不改变变量所以像这样一些简单人特性当中更容易去解释从它也能够享受所有的优化然后它官方还带了一个解释器所以就更方便一些你知道去改这个解释器
然后再改这个圣圣中间这个代码的这个过程实际上已经能得到一份就是就是照你的能力就强了然后你的前面大码什么都不用改然后你中间去改一改就行了然后具体怎么去解释执行实际上就说可能这个时候呢就需要开发开发的话就是你要去自己编一个这个解释党的自己的这个这个这个程序里面去所以你要调这个英的prata的这个接口
因为你要执行的是这个案所以你要把每一个文件都生成一个BC文件最终用AR-Link然后把他连接起来然后要自己构建一下这个地方要用到他不要发来案同时要用AR-Link去练所以这几个都是需要自己从原码去编的最后就不要讲这种解释到类传再解释事情就可以了这一块就不细说了
它实际上也就是把它解释到类水里面去然后主要用了这么几个接口然后它首先要读文件嘛读BC的文件然后解析这个model然后model里面这些东西就是AR的一个解析过程然后最后再对类水进行这样一个操作这实际上都是都是LOM的接口去完成的OK它时间应该控制的还是蛮不错的就说大概就是这样就是
首先就回归一下今天讲的这个内容就是第一个就是说我们工程对移动当代说它时间越长它就还是需要做很多的优化另外一个工程大来的编译会比较满所以还是需要有一些开发提效的一些方法就是刚才也提到了一些方案包括最近的一些想法就是说跟大家做一个分享今天的分享就到这里